Branding, or self-branding is a method of career advancement.
A brand is basically your reputation.
To work on your career brand, you need to pool your past achievements and gather new ones.
Gain experience in weak areas.
Ask for useful and demanding new projects and assignments at work.
Excel in your career and get additional education.
Learn the difference between showing off and promoting yourself.
Get a personal website that should include resumes, accomplishment lists,...
...mission statement, awards, samples of work, speech transcripts, and so on.
Remember that employers base their decisions on the number and quality of hits when googling job seekers.
Therefore, you need to have a strong online presence.
Becoming an expert in your field gives your brand more credibility than anything else.
Writing articles and getting published, giving presentations at conferences and meetings...
...and having your opinion mentioned by journalists all enhance your brand.